So you would ask that.
The question is,
the question is speech
brings order out of chaos.
That's what I said,
but it appears that speech brings
chaos out of order as well.
And the answer to that is it does.
All right.
There was only so many complications I
can address in the talk simultaneously.
Um,
if you look out,
if you look at the most
archaic of Archetipal Heroes,
those heroes confront something
that represents chaos.
It's usually a monster,
the bears a treasure of some sort.
And that's a symbolic representation
of the class of all unexplored things,
right?
Because things that we have not yet
explored are threatening and destructive,
but also offer us infinite potential,
but more elaborated hero stories,
let's say.
Also reverse that and say that,
well,
there are times when the order
has become so corrupt and rigid,
that free speech fragments it into its
parts so that it can rejuvenate itself.
And so mean the actually in the gospels,
that's the hero.
That Christ is basically represented as,
he's not so much the dragon confronting
the dragon slayer who gathers the
treasure,
although that's implicit in the,
in the juxtaposition of Christ with the
figure of like a serpent tile Satan.
But Christ is the thing that stands up
against the corrupt state and rejuvenated
through speech.
And so technically speaking,
free speech,
the logos is the thing that
mediates between chaos and order.
And you can think about
this is represented in,
in,
in many cultures this idea,
you can see it most specifically I would
say in the Taoist conceptualization
because in the Dallas world being
is made out of chaos and order,
Yin and Yang,
masculine and feminine,
fundamentally it's chaos in order in
order is the fact that wherever you go
there are things you understand in order.
And Chaos is the fact that wherever
you go there are things you don't
understand.
And so the idea is that being is made
out of the things that you understand and
the things that you don't understand.
And it's always that way,
which is why dow is the
symbol of being per se.
And it's the case.
Your brain has adapted.
In fact,
it's partly why it has two hemispheres
for the world that you understand in the
world.
You don't understand the world.
You understand roughly speaking,
being handled by the left in the world.
You don't understand roughly speaking,
being handled by the right.
Well,
it's that line down the middle.
That's dao,
that's meaning.
And if you have one foot in
chaos and one foot in order,
you're maximizing information flow and
rejuvenating yourself at the same time
that you're maintaining your structure.
And you will report on that
internally as engagement in the world.
It's the most fundamental orienting
sense that you have and it's deeply
instantiated neurologically,
unbelievably deeply.
And so it really is the case from an
evolutionary perspective that reality is
chaos and order.
It's that to which you're adapted.
And so sometimes you're speaking on
behalf of chaos and sometimes you were
speaking on behalf of border.
It's more complicated
than that too though.
Because when we have a dialog say and,
and we're,
we're mutually attempting to climb towards
the truth instead of convincing each
other that we're right,
say,
then what we're doing is
engaging in the simile.
Tanium is fragmentation of old and archaic
belief systems and they're updated.
And you can experience that because
someone will say something that sets you
back and then you'll get what they're
saying and it'll click together.
And what you're experiencing
is the death of a,
of a,
of an old conceptualization structure,
its disintegration,
and then it's
reconfiguration in a tighter,
in a tighter order.
And people love that.
They live for that.
It's,
it's,
it's really,
it's what keeps you alive.
And you can experience that
in a deep conversation,
a truthful conversation,
a meeting of the minds and soul.
And people love that.
It's curative.
All psychotherapists know this because
what you do in psychotherapy as well,
in addition to helping people face the
things that they're most afraid of so
that they can overcome them,
is to allow them to
tell someone the truth.
What happened to you all?
Listen.
So they tell you and they take themselves
apart and put themselves together.
Well,
they're speaking the truth about what
happened and it puts them together.
It's at the no,
the,
the two fundamental elements
of psychotherapy are let's
find what you're afraid
of an avoiding and help you confront it
so that you can gather the information
that's there and let's allow you to lay
your story out in all of its catastrophe
in detail so that you can straighten
yourself out through speech.
That's exactly what
happens in psychotherapy.
So when it should happen
in every real relationship,
it's,
it's the spiritual purpose
of marriage fundamentally,
right?
Because you faced someone who's different
than you that you're tied to and
cannot run from.
And so you can reveal your really,
really,
it's a critical,
it's a critical part of marriage
because if you can run from someone,
they will never show you their true face.
Because if someone shows
you their true face,
you will run.
And so you say in a marriage ceremony,
I will allow you to show me your
true face and I will not run.
And unless you mean that
you'll never be married,
you'll never understand what it means
and you'll never reap the benefits of it,
which are practical,
obviously,
but also spiritual and psychological.
There's a reason for the vow,
but it has to be a vow because otherwise
you have a back door open and you'll
never really tell the person what your
life and no bloody wonder because really
who wants to know what you're like,
God,
even you,
that's for sure.